Je suppose que je fais juste une pause, nous avons eu
cette aventure vraiment cool pour sauver la Terre
et c'était plutôt heureux de toute façon, donc j'avais
besoin de temps pour moi et je suis venu en
Australie et c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai emménagé
avec Daryl bonjour
et nous y voilà tu sais que c'est  un bel
appartement comme vous pouvez le voir et nous nous entendons
bien ouais je suppose que je voulais juste être avec
des gens ordinaires Darryl est
un type moyen de tous les jours donc ça
marche bien pendant que je suis ici j'essaie
de m'impliquer avec  les bagages
qui sont ce cinglé violet surpris que vous le sachiez en
fait mais je ne semblais pas
redonner à la communauté
Darryl voici une
lettre électronique d'artisan beauté que j'écris à Captain
America et Iron Man il semble y avoir
quelque chose de très intense entre
eux et je veux offrir mon aide mes
services cher Tony Stark comment ça va
j'ai entendu toi et Captain America nous
avons des problèmes relationnels cher
Steve Rogers te souviens-tu quand je
t'ai poussé à tuer ces prisonniers
et tu m'as fait jurer  ne jamais dire aux
autres Avengers s'il y a d'autres
secrets que vous devez garder, faites-le moi savoir
parce que je ne suis pas au courant de ce que vous
faites plus tard je travaillais ce qu'il
fait il travaille garder le
costume de Darryl pour les batailles que nous sommes tous
proches  ici en train de faire une sieste un peu
de quelque chose que je rôtis au
soleil depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant et c'est
presque prêt délicieuse question quelles sont les
pierres Infinity beaucoup d'informations et d'
idées et ce que j'aime appeler de petits
indices tachetés autour du  endroit et qui
est l'homme dans la chaise violette est violet
c'est un gant magique n'aime pas se
lever fureur que sait-il vraiment et est
fureur son vrai nom ou est-ce réellement
prononcé petit moulin poilu près d'ici des
lunettes de soleil au cas où obtenir le brillant  et
le pont arc-en-ciel, ce qu'il fait souvent
ou si vous soulevez celui-ci
qu'est-ce qu'il me tient Je ne porte jamais de
coupures comment puis-je continuer à me réveiller et à couper
des pantalons normaux qui vont dans des coupures
qui sortent vous hmm
allez serré nous avons entendu  de Tony  Stark
et Captain America ne vous ont pas contacté, je
n'ai pas reçu un seul appel téléphonique euh
euh une seconde euh-huh
hey t-bone combien de fois devons-nous
passer par là, aucune somme d'argent
ne me fera rejoindre votre  petit
concours de pisse qu'est-ce qu'ici parle à Thor ouais il
t'attendait en quelque sorte ici je l'
ai ici
oh tu ne peux pas en ce moment d'accord je suis
déçu qu'ils ne m'aient pas invité à
me battre avec lui euh non il doit se cacher
encore une fois toucher avec toi je n'ai pas de
téléphone il n'a pas de téléphone
envoie un corbeau je viens de créer ma propre équipe
équipe quatre bien sûr et ce serait moi
et Darryl juste nous d'accord